at on vraiment appris des choses dans ce
documentaire on va en parler dans un
instant avec la coréalisatrice rizlène
sediqa qui sera avec nous d'ailleurs
merci à elle de venir parce que sachez
que france télé la bloquer france 2
aussi laurent guimier voilà mon ancien
ami m'appelé beaucoup plus quand il
voulait la direction d'europe 1
m'a pas répondu il lui a demandé il lui
a demandé de ne pas venir c'est fou hein
c'est fou et voilà donc elle méprise
l'aisne vient quand même donc je
voudrais dire franchement bravo mr
et rizlène joue il dit je crois que
c'est une personnalité incroyable voilà
et je pousse c'est un gros gros talons
quoi qu'il arrive on va regarder d'abord
les salaires des influenceurs les
commissions prennent les agences qui
font le lien entre eux et les marques
qui souhaitent vendre leurs produits on
va rappeler un pont de téléspecteurs ce
que je pense que c'est ça aussi c'est
qu'hier les gens voilà il faut alors il
faut qu'on leur explique me voir moi moi
je suis pas du tout que ça franchement
je n'ai rien à carrer en fait on va pas
se mentir je vous dis la vérité je
voulais toujours dit je m'en bats les
steaks total de ces histoires
influenceurs alors tout le monde dit oui
ce que j'ai vu qu'il avait parlé de moi
aussi oui je suis dans une société dans
laquelle je suis actionnaire qui a
racheté petit actionnaire qui a racheté
jaune à evans donc voilà et c'est vrai
que je monte ça monte ça m'en touche une
sans faire bouger l'autre on va pas se
raconter d'histoires c'est vrai que je
ne suis pas voilà ce qu'ils font ils le
business des influenceurs franchement je
préfère jouer la chercheuse je connais
pas du tout ce qui se passe et je m'en
tape le cul voilà sur la nasa préfère le
dire comme sur moi le voilà le le débat
est clos voilà comme ça c'est fait et
c'est vrai que j'ai jamais fait un
placement de produit à part peut-être
pour une raquette de paddle mais que
j'ai acheté
ni franchement je le mot car le cul donc
les sommes ont choqué beaucoup de monde
gilles c'est quoi les influenceurs alors
les influenceurs ce sont des gens qui
font la promotion de produits ou de
marques en échange de rétribution et ce
qui choque est ce que le complément
d'enquêté montrer c'est que parfois ils
font ce qu'on appelle du drop shipping
c'est à dire que il achève en chine on
achète en chine un produit qui vaut 5
euros et comme on et influenceurs on le
met en lumière on fait un peu de
packaging ou pas et on leur vend 45
euros sans que c'est une arnaque voilà
voilà alors on va voir le premier à
regretter voilà les sobres ou choquer
beaucoup de monde oui regardez rizlène
venir nous rejoindre juste après la co
réalisatrice du documentaire c'est parti
pour la star nabila et ses 7 millions
300 mille abonnés les annonceurs payent
jusqu'à 10000 euros pour une course de
vidéos
pour jessica ti venin 6 million deux
cent mille abonnés c'est 7000 euros
mais sur ces sommes quelle part revient
à magali berda et à son agence nous nous
sommes procuré ce document auprès d'un
ancien employé sur cette opération
shauna events a pris une commission de
20 %
c'est parfois beaucoup plus selon
certains influenceurs contacté
en 2020 lagence de magali berda a
déclaré 3 millions d'euros de bénéfices
1 moi j'adore la musique de copé -
marquette el tomi n'aura sera mon frère
même si t'as rien fait et comme
on angoisse totale jour est remercié
vivienne syndicats d'être avec no mercy
rizlène avec plaisir sinon mais c'est
franchement merci beaucoup d'être là
voilà je sais que j'espère que ça va pas
vous causer problème mais j'espère aussi
évidemment ce que veut vraiment jusqu'au
bout et les rédacteurs en chef je veux
producteurs m'ont contacté pour ne pas
intervenir aujourd'hui mais comme je les
dis ce matin à l'émission de guillaume
genton pour moi c'est le droit
d'information donc pourquoi on pourrait
par un fort mais aussi les
téléspectateurs de cyril hanouna moi je
ne comprends pas mais pour moi c'est
aussi le vraiment la cerise sur le
gâteau parce que j'ai tenté de contacter
pour une interview mais moi je suis ça a
été très compliqué et mon voyage sans
cesse de vous à chaque fait plaisir et
ben merci en tout cas dans les séries
bravo parce que sous des noms mais ces
essais france dont voilà c'est la
direction de france 2 en direction de
l'information de france 2 qui n'a pas
voulu qu'il y ait d'intervenants moi
c'est ça qui me rend fou c'est que ils
veulent faire des enquêtes me le faire
complément d'enquêté il veut le faire il
n'y succès mais derrière ils veulent pas
nous envoyer les gens pour qu'ils
viennent s'expliquer en plateau et puis
effectivement un problème est un
problème à une pression aussi on nous on
se plaint quelquefois de pression parce
qu'on a eu des influences euse qui nous
ont contactés avec des avocats et moi je
comprends pas pourquoi me fais aussi de
la pression pour pas que j'intervienne
si j'en ai envie alors journaliste
freelance je moi je vais vous dire
quelque chose à moi je vous dire quelque
chose en tout cas qu'on aime ou pas
complément d enquête et je lis
franchement et et vous avez vu vous
l'avez dit vous-même h aux actionnaires
voilà 2010 je trouve que c'était très
bien expliqué vous comprenez tout je
trouve qu'il y avait vraiment il y avait
des révélations ont stocké passé très
vite voilà oui parce qu'on avait
vraiment une enquête non mais vraiment
c'est une enquête en fête qui dure
depuis des mois moi vraiment des mois
j'ai commencé à enquêter à partir du
mois de décembre 2021 je sais je sais
mais alors vous m'avez laissé de
nombreux messages je sais vous même
maman appelez moi je lâche pas et c'est
comme ça que j'ai eus magali berda je
sais pas non vous avez bien fait d'avoir
mais magali babin skalli directement
concernés entre nous je vous jure il a
dit oui mais oui si caisse de résonance
il y avait donc c'est quelque part
nabila sur ce plateau
enfin quand je dis non je fais sur des
plateaux qui vous l'avez deviné certaine
crédibilité voyez ce que j'ai passé à
l'émoi en fait je l'avais prise à l'eba
à la base nabila parce que c'est vrai
que c'était un phénomène jamais eu le
moindre différence entre gap et elle
fait l'amour est aveugle à la barre elle
avait fait des émissions de téléréalité
et c'est vrai que je cherchais quelqu'un
un moment je cherchais quelqu'un qui
symbolise la télé-réalité c'est ça que
je me suis dit la patronne ça reste
nabila et c'est vrai que nabil a bien
voulu venir et j'ai démarré en fait sept
enfants cette enquête en me demandant
mais qui sont les nouvelles et nouveaux
nabila en fait ça angoua là et j'ai
découvert maeva guen a mis la serbie
mais je pense moi sérieusement je pense
qu'il n'y aura plus de nouvelles nabila
je pense que nabila ç'a été l'apogée
comme comme je pense comme vous mais 10
à 20 je pense aussi qu'en tennis n'aura
plus de binômes star de télé voilà et il
est de chabannes ya comme un baume les
dames siège voile assad était derrière
énormément de messages mais il ya plus
je trouve de voile à des normes
influenceurs alors on a on en apprend un
peu plus derrière sur la rémunération
d'une des stars de télé-réalité milla
jasmin qui totalisent plus de 3,2
millions d'euros elle n'hésite pas à
avouer face caméra les sommes
astronomiques qu'elle gagne voilà on va
voir cet extrait qui a fait énormément
parler on va voir les plusieurs extraits
sains qui font qu'on prépare les regarde
mis l'injure utiliser ce produit
régulièrement pour perdre du poids il
serait très efficace
mon code promo vous avez au moins 22%
sur tous les produits jce internet il a
décoché entre 500 et 1500 euros pour une
publication qui va rester 24 heures sur
ces réseaux et voilà tu m'envoies tout
bien ouais elle en ferait en moyenne une
cinquantaine par l'oie ya des mois où on
peut faire quinze mille euros via
d'autres moi ou pas faire soixante mille
euros
[Musique]
c'est pas que c'est pas tabou pour moi
mais mais oui je suis millionnaire
alors c'est vrai que ça fait énormément
parler ça cette affaire - est-ce que ça
vous a choqué s'avouer valérie bénaïm ne
savent pas ce qu'est parce que je suis
pas tombé de l'armoire en fait j'étais
sur une armoire compte
garder mais moi je sais que vous avez
énormément travaillé je veux pas
dénigrer votre travail mais pour moi la
montagne a accouché d'une souris oh là
là moi jamais mais bon alors je m y sens
il faut défendre je veux défendre des
semaines très vite parce que je sais ce
que vous allez lire valérie bénaïm je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi vous dites
ça et je pense que risen fait d'accord
avec monsieur vous de bien vous vous
êtes dans le milieu valérie bénaïm vous
connaissez tout ce qui se passe les
influenceurs ma mère elle n'y connaît
rien hier à la regarder complément
d'enquêté je peux vous dire qu'elle a
appris plein de trucs là je suis désolé
c'est raide dingue et là vous regarde
pas du tout là je dois dire en touche
pas à mon poste on a évoqué avec toi
gaming arrêtée là du tout mais alors si
on la laisse documentaire avant déjà
déjà avant qu'on en parle puisque on en
a parlé à la rentrée le documentaire
était prévu et à la elle a travaillé
depuis un an dessus je sais plus depuis
décembre mais dit il la retient voilà
donc plus d'un an dessus donc là je vous
dis parce que vous êtes vous êtes en
fait vous êtes déconnecté les
téléspectateurs mais et même mois
comprenez rien aujourd'hui parce que
j'ai jamais suivi parce que ça ne
m'intéressait pas du tout j'ai voulu
voir un petit peu passé parce que je
croyais me suivez vous avez déjà vu
passer mille à jasmine parme sur votre
plateau dont elle a dû penser je les
fais pas ci fais pas ça
non mais c'est mène en mairie mais c'est
vrai que voilà donc là
c'est comme vous dites c'est les
téléspectateurs en fait deux on a
vraiment voulu révéler ses sources et
écosystèmes cette galaxie pas où il est
personne est en fait c'est les réseaux
sociaux oui nous on connaît les outils
sociaux mais bien la plongée parce que
après je veux pas non plus avoir un
jugement sur les téléspectateurs de
complément d'enquêté mais je pense qu'on
leur a révélé beaucoup d'un slogan est
ce que leurs enfants regardent bah oui
c'est ça exactement c'est ça alors on
apprend également que certains produits
vendus par des influenceurs peuvent être
dangereux ça c'était un grand moment un
moment important baladant dans ce
documentaire on ce reportage c'est
notamment le cas de cindy une influence
us qui dit avoir perdu ses cheveux à
cause d'un shampooing vendus par
l'entreprise oui events6 appartient
arthur on s'est fait ça prend un faucon
et à la même mission arthur et moi
et regarder il s'agissait d'une affaire
voilà donc les la toile s'est emparé
c'est vrai que c'est assez préoccupant
programme
avant même la diffusion une agence de
placement de produits lui propose un
contrat oui events l'âge ans a elle
aussi été rachetée par un grand groupe
satisfaction dirigé par l'animateur
arthur qui produit les anges de la télé
réalité où la villa des coeurs brisés
une fois le contrat signé cindy touche
100 euros par vidéo où elles placent des
produits comme ses shampooings vendu
plus de 30 euros le flacon est en fait
au bout d'une semaine d'utilisation j'ai
déjà des cheveux qui commence à changer
et dès que je sors de la douche que je
me coiffe cd poignée de cheveux qui
commencent à tomber en fait j'ai encore
les avis des gens qui s'affiche sur les
projets moi j'ai testé grosse perte de
cheveux démangeaisons savons rien j'ai
une mycose à cause d'une et sans
encombrement sur les avis des personnes
qui ont utilisé aucune utilisent ces
produits là que je me dis de problème il
vient de là en fait merci bonsoir aisés
ont discuté un petit peu et crise n
rizlène ça cet extrait c c'est un moment
fort parce que c'est voilà ça on se dit
il ya tout vous avez parlé des
téléspectateurs qui paraît qu'ils
pensent à leurs enfants on se dit voilà
tous les enfants qui vont voir tous les
ados qui vont acheter ces produits là ça
c'est un moment compliqué oui absolument
elle perd ses cheveux car il ya une
grande communauté aussi donc il ya un
bon groupe sur les réseaux sociaux qui
regroupe des victimes en fait on voulait
donner la parole aux victimes et là la
victime c'est une en faisant ce genre m
dont victimes du produit et de deauville
et nakache donc qui est le dirigeant de
800 qui fait partie du groupe
satisfaction mais il avait terminé un
problème lui il avait un problème lui
c'est parce que je crois qu'il avait
quittée mois satisfait parce qu'en fait
c'est quoi donc c'est ça alors je vous
explique pas ce que cool explique bien
les deux boîtes d'influenceurs il ya
deux grosses agences ya shauna evans
magali berna qui devait être acheté par
arthur à la base et qui a été choisi de
racheter par banide g productions qui
est un grand groupe dirigé par stéphane
courbit avec plusieurs actionnaires
ils ont dit voilà que j'étais dans le
groupe et ses terres et ja oui havens
qui étaient plus petits la base qui a
été racheté par arthur qui n'a pas eu
magali bernat il a voulu racheter ou
eleven et a eu un petit souci je crois
avec le dirigeant de wild bunch et plus
j'ai pas suivi il ya deux ans pas moins
de temps et je croyais qu'il avait dit
oui mis dehors c'est qui ce oui cela je
sais pas quoi oui cela nakache voilà
alors ce qu'il y avait eu un problème
avec des tweets des messages sur les
réseaux sociaux raciste très violent on
les a derrière nous voilà on en a
derrière cyril voilà et moi et scène ce
que je n'ai pas compris c'est que vous
l'interrogez sur les shampoings nous
aller au bout vraiment votre
documentaire moi il m'a plu vous allez
au bout de manière serrée avec magali
berda mais pourquoi vous reparler après
de magali oui mais pourquoi vous n'avez
pas fait la même chose avec il n'a pas
voulu répondre
oui mais les gouttes alors oui
mais c'est moi - cours ajoute magali
pour le coup quand on veut pas vous
répondre ici elle a fait quoi ici vous
étiez entrée voyez ça avait été un peu
serré qu'à laisser dans l'ue mais
pourquoi vous n'avez pas fait pareil
avec lui je trouve que vous l'avez
beaucoup épargné alors qu'il ya des
messages alors que lui même avait nié
puis s'est excusé et on pensait la
société avait dit qu'elle avait quittée
parce qu'il était introuvable c'est ça
que je vois pas de changer monsieur
hanouna je sais où trouver magali berda
mais en revanche vous êtes nakache et
puis on est on est qu'au réalisateur bah
oui voilà vous avez bien vu que la
personne qui au téléphone c'est mon co
réalisateur paul labrosse donc voilà il
l'a fait tourner il mais il lui a promis
à abandonner il a cru à une interview
mais finalement c'est passé mais on l'a
eu au téléphone
alors justement justement au téléphone
on allait on à l'extrait d'abord on va
voir que cindy est obligé de se raser la
tête regardez après d'avoir utilisé ses
champions
c'en est trop pour cindy qui rompt son
contrat quant à ses cheveux elle opte
pour une solution radicale qu'elle a
bien sûr mises en ligne sur ces réseaux
pas c'est à dire le shaq parce que pour
une femme c'est un choc de voir ce rêve
de la tête là me voir comme ça les
cheveux rasés rct c'était dur en
j'en veux à lagence mais à la marque à
la marque parce que je ne comprends pas
encore à l'heure actuelle comment ce
genre de produit puisse exister est ni
sur les marchés en fait alors vous avez
donc tenté de joindre le wesley le
patron de williams pour qu'il se
justifie sur cette activité est
apparemment oui t'es pas comme un ouf
que vous l'appeliez regarder ouah c'est
la khl a refusé nos demandes d'interview
nous l'avons appelé il ne sait pas qu'il
est enregistré
pourquoi il y avait des substances
interdites pourquoi ça a continué d'être
vendue à cette époque en 2008 les
erreurs de notre de notre fournisseur et
la cosmétologie et des choses qui seront
autorisés et tous les ans il ya des
produits qui peuvent être des amateurs
est ce que votre métier c'est de vendre
des shampoings c'est aussi une des
questions
le projet devra être entrepreneur c'est
un métier d'être entrepreneur et de
pouvoir monter des business oui non
c'est très bien d'avoir sensibilisé le
public de france 2 sur les dangers d'un
change pour les enfants potentiel c'est
bien aussi d'avoir montré qu'il ya
plusieurs agences qui sont concernés et
là ce qui est doublement grave c'est que
non seulement c'est cette agence donc la
chance de jouer c'est qu'ils proposent
ça mais en plus c'est sa marque c'est
lui qui produit ses propres shampoing
l'occurrence qui sont dangereux pour la
santé et ça chauffe que vous l'avez bien
la balle et vous l'avez pas épargné pour
le coup donc ça pour le coup l'enquète
été bien fait maturer mais ces points de
pompes pour moi il est là le vrai
scandale parlons c'est surtout ça c'est
que c'est quand tout d'un coup
malheureusement les agences d' influence
se sont dit que plus de ce qu'à 20 % de
commission elle pourrait s'en faire 100%
en vendant leurs propres marques et
c'est là que c'est devenu dangereux
parce qu'effectivement la cosmétologie
tout ça tant qu'ils vendaient les
marques des autres divisions du vent du
l'oréal mais tu prends une commission
bon on aime ou on n'aime pas mais c'est
l'axé du dangereux c'est quand ils ont
commencé à se dire qu'il pourrait faire
beaucoup d'argent en vendant leurs
propres produits des produits coupe faim
des produits pour les cheveux et c'est
là où c'est devenu vraiment vraiment
vraiment dangereux pour la santé et
c'est là où c'est devenu dangereux
effectivement et qu'il avait fallu que
certains influenceurs pardon je
maintenant mais moi j'avais refusé des
coupes-faim se mettre dedans parce que
là c'est pour la santé des gamins
beaucoup se demandent pourquoi la
plupart des influenceurs les plus connus
se retrouve à dubaï certains ont
d'ailleurs plier bagage pour y habiter
la raison est toute simple un bien
entendu les impôts tout simplement voilà
donc bravo à vous devez rester là
je vais vous dire pourquoi moi je vous
paye de moins en moins pour que va payer
de moins en moins d'un an
regardez la vidéo de nina et sa copine
ressemble à une banale chorégraphie mais
c'est un placement de produit une marque
de maillots de bain paye nina pour cette
publication est plutôt bien
de l'argent du soleil mais pas seulement
à dubaï le paradis est aussi fiscale
quand un business qui marche c'est
pourtant trahi tout ce que tu fais ça va
bien pour toi et tu donneras ans
d'autres et j'ai cette fois ci encore
plus musclé le matin tu as la
loi 01 tri zéro impôt c voilà
ça joue aussi en fait qu'on est venus
ici bien sûr en masse le gâchis que moi
non
ah oui gilles ils ont voulu retirer la
séquence c'est ça
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'était des
messages vraiment intempestifs et
ensuite des courriers d'avocat pour moi
pour découvrir d'avocate pour retirer
leur séquence est donc ce qui dérange
dans cette séquence mais cette année on
le sait qu'ils s'arrêtent pas pour ça on
sait très bien que c'est pas parce que
ils ont ils font de la piscine à vagues
comme il est dit
des particuliers avec les influenceurs
c'est bon après ça on sa peugeot
dernancourt portage entourent
documentaire il y a souvent des
rétractations après il faut essayer de
convaincre de rassurer en tous les cas
moi c'est ma méthode voilà donc c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de faire et
mais les influenceurs au début ils vous
donnent énormément
ensuite ils réfléchissent et puis ils
ont peur pourquoi parce que il y aussi
ce tabou de l'argent je pense en france
2 i rui on gagne beaucoup d'argent ou
voilà il y en a qui vivent à dubaï et
qui paye matin mais ce qui dérange
surtout je vous dis la vérité
les téléspectateurs moi ce que je pense
c'est ce que disait raymond à la fois
que kylie ann m pap et gagnent beaucoup
d'argent ça dérange pas que un immense
acteur gagnent beaucoup d'argent un
immense humoriste ça dérange moins mais
là en fait je pense que les gens se
disent qu'elle est leur talent pour
gagner autant d'argent c'est ça en fait
qui dérange et qui gagnent des millions
est ce que ça nous dérange pas non c'est
pas tout à fait pareil c'est pas mal
mais aussi elle est jeune elle est belle
à voir ce sont des choses qui dérangent
moi ça me dérange pas qu'ils gagnent
beaucoup d'argent non plus juste ces
deux c'est très bien pour eux ce qui
dérange c'est que nos portes à dubaï pas
d'impôts vont dire ici se faire soigner
ou à coucher profiter d z social mais
salvatrice alors la
[Applaudissements]
triste mais dans ces cas là on va plus
loin et on prend tous les grands
sportifs qu'on aime qui sont français
qui vivent en suisse en belgique on a
plein de noms ont fait un complément d
enquête dessus on les insulte pas et
parce que moi je suis d'accord pour ça
allait pas d'accord non mais tu vois ce
que vous allez allez pas d'accord non
plus mais après on parle elle a du
talent on sait les clients voilà il
visionnait voilà une action pas trop de
talent et c'était un mal acquis un
sportif il a un talent je suis désolé
c'est moi mais tout est relatif quand
même parce que là on parle de talent
mais moi je défends pas ces personnes gg
pas d'amis dans ce moule non plus
complètement mais quand on sait quand
même des créateurs de contenu et c'est
un divertissant mais y'en a des craintes
on dira que c'est des dinos ariane qui
travaillent avec nous c'est un créateur
de contenu d'un talent certain savoir
faire la part des choses entre les
créateurs de contenus et les
influenceurs de télé réalité mais même
de la télé réalité le match juste un nom
il y en a qui ont du talent oui et après
on les met tous dans le même sac je veux
dire à un moment donné ces gens là aussi
ils ont proposé des choses s'ils sont
connus sont les fils et les gens qui les
suit au flux du site à tout vent de
l'intérêt mais aujourd'hui les gens qui
en fait moi l'idée du reportage c'était
vraiment un décryptage donc il y avait
en aucun cas un jugement que je porte
sur ces personnes moi je ne juge pas on
décrypte on est là chacun fait le choix
de sa vie décide voilà là c'était un
phénomène de société il avait un
business et c'était ça qu'il fallait
révélé des fêtes aux téléspectateurs de
complément d'enquêté et aux
téléspectateurs de cyril hanouna ce soir
merci bas ça va c'est beaucoup en
remercie et je trouve très dur c'est
parce que enfin pas me réduiront le
maître est paumé si nabila n'a aucun
talent particulier dit nabil un avocat
talent rouge les prises ici non enfin
que des jantes allons regarder aux
toiles et des inférences heures à m'en
parler les gens qui gagnent de l'argent
sans rien faire non mais je dis moi je
me fais l'avocat du diable aussi et je
dise que ce que je vois sur les réseaux
et moi c'est vrai qu'à plein de potes à
moi qui me disent regardez raymond la
fois il a dit ouais ça lui les loulous
et on prend bien non consciente des
influenceurs je suis désolé mais du
matin au soir ils sont comme ça du matin
au soir ils sont justement et c'est ce
que j'ai été comme ça et justement
pourquoi vous dites ça des influences
heures du matin aux soins ils sont vidés
et ils sont vidés et ils ont des
tendinites comme magali hier c'est vrai
magali est elle atteinte d'une tendinite
au moins c'est la question qu'on se pose
également maman
on va prendre un exemple et vous allez
nous expliquer c'est vous qui avez fait
la publicité pour une montre et vous
fait croire que vous utilisez cette
montre alors qu'en fait vous l'avez
jamais porté qu'est ce que vous en
voulez pas aujourd'hui en tout cas non
mais qu'est ce que vous en savez que je
ne la porte pas voulu porter qu'est ce
que vous en oui j'en ai je déjà porté
bien sûr à me connecter gelé déjà porté
bien sûr une tendinite au bras donc j'ai
déjà porté
meilleur moment pour moi
moi c'est le meilleur moment du
reportage
oui elle a fait du paddle également
apparemment non mais c'est vrai voilà
donc magali a une dent tinto bras non ça
va ça va mieux paraît-il j'ai eu les
médecins
et alors magali berda c'est elle que
vous vouliez c'est parce que c'est
pourquoi c'est elle qui représente
vraiment le monde des influenceurs
aujourd'hui donc à l'époque où j'ai
contacté magali berda il faut se
rappeler que elle faisait les immersions
politique te sens qu'elle passait
d'adjoindre d'influenceurs à interviewer
vous passez de quand vous pensez de
compassé de paga des marseillais à eric
zemmour oui emmanuel macron elle a quand
même eu tur emmanuel macron qu'amd de
nombreux journalistes ont tenté de
l'avoir il l'avait pas ce moment là même
nom des mêmes nous on n'y a pas eu un on
a eu un manuel makrouds un banc dehors
donc c'est vrai qu'on confond ses
intérêts c'est donc un magali béria
parce que bon voilà c'est la papesse de
l influence en scène courtière
d'assurance ruiner c'est une sorte aussi
de succès story et en même temps il y à
des dérives dans son entreprise donc on
les a décrypté il ya des blogueurs comme
vos stars en réalité stop arnaques qui
décrypte tout cela on a voulu là
confrontés à cela alors elle est ce
qu'elle est là elle a accepté de
répondre contrairement à la casse n'a
dit la dre s'il n'était pas facile parce
qu'elle m'en voyez d'abord l'assistante
contacté des rendez-vous pas tenu
donc ça a été la croix et la bannière
aussi pourra pour la rencontrer et leur
énorme émoi la latte et au moins à la
farewell je raconte juste la généalogie
oasis est important donc et le réseau
orion l'interview là c'est vrai qu'elle
nous a elle été méfiant aussi en voilà
moi je la découvrais mais elle avait
beaucoup de méfiance est donc au départ
elle voulait voir le film un peu
beaucoup de témoins sont comme ça en
revanche elle nous a ouvert les
prud'hommes et en changeant quelques uns
fait toujours un peu plus et on est
boisé comme je le disais ce mec
complément d enquête ça fait toujours un
peu flipper non mais c'est vrai oui
c'est parce que c'est une ciné musique
parce qu'on sait qu'on sait qu'on va pas
arriver à dire magali mais reverser la
plus belle c'est la meilleure elle peut
en or mais si on l'a fait il ya quelques
années ah oui il ya quelques années au
tout début de son entreprise elle l'a
fait d'accord c'est que ça va être des
documents à charge mais encore plus dans
cash d'investigation ou là assurément
quoi qu'on dise on se fait dégommer
taches rousses et est ce que c'est ce
que j'ai enregistré que c'est équilibré
dans le document c'est que c'est
équilibré ça que vous avez laissé la
parole à magali à labouheyre les ports
dont je trouve qu'elle a fait vraiment
on veut transparente faudra essayer il
ya eu des critiques que vous avez
dénoncé deux pas des pratiques vous avez
dénoncé mais je trouve qu'il avait
laissé le temps de s'exprimer voulais
pas casser je crus c'était assez
équilibré ce que j'ai bien aimé dans le
documentaire mais on n'est pas là pour
mettre à terre longeant de très bien
alors il ya une séquence qui a fait
beaucoup réagir qui avait d'ailleurs été
tourné avant la diffusion du médoc qui
avait déjà tourné avant il avait foule
et fait sortir c'est normal c'est de
bonne guerre pour appâter les
téléspectateurs magali berda s'énerve
contre l'un de vos journalistes estimant
avoir été piégée par une question où
elle n'était pas préparée sur des
placements de produits accusés d'être
des contrefaçons de garder
sa place et le mien c'est mieux passé
c'est moi je n'ai pas pu vérifier si
c'était de chez moi déjà sur certaines
d'entre elles n'apparaissent pas parce
que je vais pas me sentir piégé en ce
sens que je n'ai pas les éléments de
réponse alors
finalement la patronne des influenceurs
acceptera de s'expliquer le lendemain
alors il ya mon ami mon frérot nino
ariana qui m'envoient je sais pas si ça
peut aider au débat mais en connaissant
bien le milieu de l'influencent de
l'intérieur je peux t'assurer que les
influenceurs et les agents savent très
bien que les produits sont merdiques les
influenceurs n'ont jamais utilisé le
produit avant d'en faire la promo et
nous l'utiliserons plus jamais après la
formule est simple tu me payes je fais
ta pub alors c'est c'est ce qui nous dit
après je demande aux gens ne m'en
doutais un peu voilà ça c'est vrai pour
tous les gens qui font de la pub et bien
sûr que tu veux pas que je crois que tu
veuilles à l'idée m'était des lunettes
optic 2000 mais
voilà on va partir dit oui gilles verdez
le point qui m'a gêné c'est au tour de
la transparence de magali berda qui se
retourne contre elle et encore une fois
je vous lis elle a le mérite de répondre
à vos très bonne question il ya des très
belles séquences mais quand vous prenez
la société de monsieur nakache oui event
là je trouve que vous n'avez pas été au
bout du travail il y avait des tweets
islamophobe il ya un communiqué de la
société oui lady qui l'a mis il a été
mis fin à ses fonctions de président et
quand on regarde aujourd'hui sur
satisfaction d'arthur wii est venu
encore monsieur nakache ça ça aurait dû
vous interpeller on a ça derrière nous
je comprends pas pourquoi vous êtes allé
aussi loin et bravo avec magali berda et
pourquoi vous n'avez pas été aussi loin
avec l'autre société répondez moi
franchement est ce que vous vouliez un
tout petit peu vous payez magali bertin
pas du tout alors pourquoi n'avoir pas
c'est la même chose on a contacté vous
n' a calmé le jeu dictent pendant des
mois et des mois on l'a contacté et il a
refusé toute demande est ternie comment
voulez-vous mais ça c'était sur les
raisons de presque 10 à des questions
aussi interloqué rêves ses tweets sur
les réseaux il ya les communiqués nous
on les a alors
non mais on vient de parler des produits
donc des produits toxiques et que des
influenceurs n'utilise pas forcément les
pôles là on voit dans notre complément
d'enquêté qui a une influence ceux qui
utilisent les produits éclipsant les
cheveux il a décrypté
coma qui fait énormément de minutes dans
le film ils ont donc fait on a fait
notre travail bien sûr autour des
williams a caché quoi son voit quand
même ils ont montré quand même le truc
c'est le truc qui a été le sc bâtiment
le wind fire shampooing à l'intérieur
justement pour lui faire croire qu'on
est allée un poil a alors en tout cas
beaucoup attendait sa réponse sur le
drop shipping à magali berda on va
rappeler ce que c'est que dans ping
dropshipping c'était gros demande un
progrès et achète un euro et tu revends
50 euros c'est ça voilà en faisant
croire qu'on fait nos affaires en
faisant voir benard l'achète en chine et
on le revend à des jeunes bah ouais
quand même alors là évoqué le sujet face
à tristan regarder le problème c'est pas
justement cette technique du drop
shipping le fait qu'on ait des des
influenceurs ou des influenceurs qui
vendent des produits qu'ils ne
connaissent pas qui sont revendus
finalement beaucoup plus cher qu'ils ne
valent réellement dans le même panier
déjà le drop shipping aujourd'hui ça
représente que 5 % de chiffre d'affaires
ce qui est assez qu'aujourd'hui on peut
pas remettre en cause toute une économie
c'est-à-dire que vous allez trouver
aussi votre paire de baskets à des prix
vous pouvez la trouver aussi en chine
fable ou peut-être qu'elle va être élevé
enfin en fait je peux pas moins
réinventer l'économie française
alors oui oui si vous en pensez de sa
réponse
ben c'est une réponse
qu'est-ce que vous êtes sa réponse bah
c'est une réponse de magali bernard
bonsoir island bonsoir je pensais de sa
réponse c'est à dire non mais vous a
convaincu ou pas
cessé elle nous répond souvent ce genre
en fait de discours
donc c'est une réponse qui est
typiquement magali berda c'est à dire
elle s'est toujours quoi répondre je
crois que c'est mr
[Musique]
bah là où leur pardon mais là où
l'enquêté mon là où l'enquêté moyenne
c'est qu'est ce que vous pensez de sa
réponse elle dit que top spin ces 5% de
son chiffre d'affaires vous devriez pas
dire bah je sais pas c'est ce qu'elle
répond si l'enquêté bien fait de dire
aider vous devriez dire non elle ment on
a vérifié c'est plus oui c'est le bon
chiffre oui c'est là où je pense que
votre enquête
son enquête aux jambes
une enquête fait complément d enquête
c'était des mvno et puis non mais
attendez pas eu des enquêtes arrête j'ai
appris le mois j'ai appris des trucs
alors c'est vrai pour monsieur ping 1 5%
bas non mais entre temps elle l'a c'est
pas une question qu'on sait pas c'est
que nous on a exploré d explorer des
dérives et une interview dont on a
interviewé des personnes qui sont
acteurs de ces dérives donc voilà et
donc dans le film on explique bien ce
qui se passe c'est que y'a les histoires
donc du drop shipping il ya les dérivés
autour de la chirurgie esthétique il ya
donc énormément de placement de produit
qui qui ne sait qui ne sont pas en règle
donc les produits toxiques donc voilà
non non on l'a on l'a expliqué on l'a
relancé donc je sais pas ce que vous
attendez là exactement elle arrive à
temps de rien vous croyez vraiment
qu'ils attendent des jumeaux qu'elle
rizlène les haines et un autre truc
benjamin castaldi
n'a rien fait hélas rien fait et s'est
retrouvé dans une sauce les caméras de
l'émission ont suivi donc magali berda
patronne de shauna est bonne dans ses
locaux et je sais même pas moi même je
n'ai pas de mots de fille sera riche sur
les cinq ans que ça mais je vais y aller
il n'avait jamais dit bah non je vous
dis pas tout sert il travaille chez
shawn a in alsace où il fait quoi il est
commercial qui fait du commerce il
fallut commerce
c'est vrai ils cherchent des produits
effectivement il est proposé
il fait très bien son boulot et j'en
suis sûr
qu'il est là bas ce qui fait bien son
fils fait du prospect s'appelle mais
c'est incroyable alors derrière cet
hymne au déferlement vous concernant vu
que ce serait donc pour cette raison que
vous prendriez souvent la défense de
shauna even though they pnp puisque j'ai
peur que votre fille se retrouvent au
chômage alors benjamin castaldi
avez-vous des intérêts à défendre
monsieur castaldi on regarde l'extrait
on en parle dans un masque en benjamin
castaldi soyez transparent mais tout
dire la transparence ici la transparence
ici on travaille un peu en famille
julien et on aime le showbiz
ça fait quatre ans 400
contre et sa chérie et en attendant un
heureux événement donc j'ai demi et a
alors alors alors alors alors comment
ils les envoient quand il est rentré
chez shawn à evans oui il travaille chez
h2o il était en stage chez vous non mais
oui
[Rires]
va bien kabbani jay il ya des vases
communicants
non mais rizlène non mais je t'explique
j'aime beaucoup et beaucoup mais il
s'est fait rêver moi je suis 90% paddon
je vais te dire savoir le fils de
castaldi a fait un stage chez nous donc
après il ya près il est rentré il est
rentré chez shauna events il est même
rentré un petit poucet main qui l'a fait
rentrer qui l'a fait entrer c'est magali
cd je connaissais bien sûr elle a
remporté sur le bateau de 10 mois et
donc elles sont devenus copains mama et
donc il a il a gravi des échelons et
maintenant il a un poste de commercial
mais en plus quel est le problème toi et
s offusquer de tout mais ça existe
toutes les autres j'étais toujours le
fils de machin qui est embauchée en
stage parce que c'est le bateau puisque
ma non mais franchement faut arrêter ce
qui est de
3,6 et les nuls il est viré par
charreyron 100 fois son père il est le
fils est toujours là
c'est vrai mais c'est passé par ses
maréchaux paris
[Applaudissements]
lee
oui rizlène le documentaire at il été
raccourci ouais pareil on sent qu'il a
été rabotée risk and j'adore votre au
delà du tessin c'est rien du tout c'est
pas du tout non alors là non je vous
assure ça couine est décédé moi je la
cuisine oui après
le décès d'elizabeth ii la reine alors
ça c'est un scoop voilà donc elle est
décédée et qu'est ce qui s'est passé et
bien on l'a été
déprogrammé ça oui voilà mais rien rien
rien raboter objets rien est ce quelque
chose dans le film que vous regrettez de
ne pas avoir misé
par exemple la jury de magali berda vous
avez intervenu pendant deux noms ne
regrette pas parce qu'elle se défend
très bien mais gagner un service
juridique et ensuite elle est source sur
le plateau dans les voiles à lui demandé
alors en interview à ce moment là pour
pas la m c'est à dire hors avoir des
explications des éclaircissements sur le
drop que nous si on sait on si on a
demandé avril soit présente oui on n'a
pas demandé à ce qu'il soit passé elle
qui exigeait que ça jury soit séparé
d'elle il ya beaucoup d'influenceurs qui
étaient floutés dans le reportage est ce
que ça veut dire que vous avez cédé aux
pressions maintenant les influenceurs
qu'on a foot est en fait un panneau quoi
comment oui donc on la sait nos services
juridiques qui ont des crimes des six
nations bien sûr donc voilà donc sa
cécité normal ça oui mais vraiment rien
et je vous le dis tous dans les yeux
rien n'a été changé au contraire et on a
eu beaucoup de chance d'être diffusée
dimanche c'est un lieu que je dis mais
c'est pas que c'était mieux c'est que on
n'a pas attendu en avril ont diffusé
dimanche justement pour ne pas risquer
d'avoir des référés et pressions ou des
gens s'ils portent plainte et des
avocats qui l'organisent enlever ces
séquences absolue est la seule manière
que ça passe intégralement fait ça